this is Gibson's dusk tiger is there a
third generation of robotic guitars now
what really makes this guitar special is
it's the most customizable guitar that
I've ever seen and you can auto tune it
you have complete control over the
strings there's a computer interface
where you can match the eq's of
different pickups and you can change all
the tunings with a single knob you can
play an open e open d you can change
your pickups from single coil to double
coil out of phase in phase there's a
piezo pickup in it so you can make it
sound like an acoustic guitar as well as
changing the tone of your guitar and my
new ways it's never been possible before
so here's how the guitar works it's
battery-powered and once you pull the
switch on first it's going to want you
to tune and choose the tuning that you
want I usually play the other standard
tuning which is marked with the S on the
control knob and then you'll just strum
the strings and if they're not in tune
already you'll see the tuning machines
tuning it up to where they should be and
then all the notes will flash green and
then you're in tune and now the second
setting it will automatically switch
over to your tone settings which are
green on the led and you can change on
their presets to your custom tone
settings and these won't affect the
acoustics of the guitar but once you
plug it in these will load all of your
custom tone settings what's different
about this guitar than most Gibson's is
the pickups which has a little knob on
it itself which blends in the piezo
pickup feed into your regular guitar
and so you can have it like a regular
Gibson would be or you can have it sound
more like an acoustic for anywhere in
between
[Music]
what makes dust Tiger more than just an
expensive toy is the software that it
comes with where you can customize your
tunings your tone and the EQ for all the
pickups on the guitar so the interface
is pretty simple over here you have your
tuning where you can click on each of
the strings and decide which frequency
you want it to be tuned to using the
robotic knob that we showed you before
over here you can modify both whether
your pickups are single coil double coil
out of phase in phase you turn the piezo
pickup off or on and you can go in and
mess with a four band EQ for your
magnetic pickups and your piezo pickup
all these settings are saved down here
along with all the automated settings
and you just plug in your guitar to the
interface here and you sync it up and
you can download all the custom settings
that you made right on to your guitar
and they'll be ready for you when you
boot it up the next time so part of the
mystique of the dust Tiger is actually
the case that it comes in which is
either a bonus or a negative depending
on how you look at it it says dust tiger
right on the outside so you know what
you're playing and I call it uncaging
the tiger because it's got this awesome
tiger print on the inside so that greets
you every time you could play your
guitar so the dust tiger is over $4,000
which is pretty steep for any guitar and
a Gibson you can find a lot of their
other guitars that are a bit nicer in
other ways for that price but you do get
a lot of customization with this guitar
and it sounds great it sounds like
Gibson one big drawback for me and I
think a lot of people is the looks of
the guitar which aren't you know it
looks like it could be Will Ferrell's
character in anchorman Ron Burgundy's
guitar or it looks like you need a
circular bed that rotates to play this
and your silk pajamas
but if you don't like that you know over
$4,000 is a lot to spend but that with
the software the customization the
automation and all the tone controls you
can get at least four or five sounds
that you're really happy with out of
this guitar so if the looks don't bother
you and you have the money and you can
spend it on something that's more of a
novelty then this is a great guitar and
you'll be really happy with it